legendary bass player Alfonso Johnson
has played with Santana Genesis weather
report and many others now he's in
Germany giving amateur musicians some
pointers to be able to touch someone
through the music to reach into someone
and change the way that they feel about
that moment that's the good bass player
a good musician period the location is
Warwick basses Factory in mark no kyojin
Saxony
hans-peter Villefort founded the company
in 1982 at first hardly anyone took
notice of the vases made in Germany
English name or not
this is the first instrument that made
the breakthrough it belonged to John
Entwistle former bass player for the who
in the late 1980s my service
back then it was real rock and roll
whether at the trade fairs or parties
going through the night or when John
trashed a room at the Savoy Hotel in
Frankfort what's a meet even if it got
smashed to pieces on stage a Warwick in
the hands of a superstar brought in new
customers every bass produced by Warwick
in Germany is one-of-a-kind the wood
used the design and the number of
pickups are a matter of the buyers
preference and the price a bass can cost
anywhere from 2,500 to 25,000 euros the
orders range from 50 to 150 instruments
per month not enough to keep the company
afloat Warwick has its more basic models
made in China and Korea under the
company's strict supervision to make
sure they live up to its quality
standards without our production in
China we couldn't survive because to a
great extent we financed our location in
Germany from the profits we make on the
models from China we have to have that
financial boost in this but you should
bear in mind that our product
development our creativity is here in
1995 Hans Peter Villefort moved the
company from Bavaria to Saxony close to
the Czech border
he says he happened upon mark Nike Ocean
by chance the town has a long tradition
of instrument making at one time it was
the foundation of its prosperity
nowadays production is on a modest scale
even after eighteen years the factory
still doesn't quite fit into the town
scape but work has put mark no Kishon
back on the international music scenes
map especially for one week of the year
when 30 world-famous musicians get
together with some 80 amateurs not all
of them play Warwick vases but the
gathering serves its purpose even so I'm
convinced that in the long term this is
a smart marketing strategy it has
far-reaching effects because the ones
who've been here takes something away
with not just an advertising slogan or a
brochure they take an experience with
them and that experience goes on right
through the night when the local pub is
turned into a stage
big names in jazz and rock Jam with
unknowns and this is where it's
happening